foreign
welcome to Kara's dream boot kickoff
event uh I'm Marvin and I will be
hosting here this event and I will be
going through the details of our sprints
just a seconds
a second yeah
and welcome
so the schedule for your our event is
that I'm going to go through all of the
details of the Sprint and then we will
host the first author of Dreamboat
Nathaniel Ruiz
and then we will have a short talk on
Keras CV by the creator of Keras
Francois chole and then we will have
apolinario from the diffusers team to
talk about diffusers and how to
train Dreamboat using diffusers and
lastly we will have a short briefing by
Nima on the consentful category which I
will be elaborating in this talk
but what is the dream buff it's a
technique fine tuning technique for
stable diffusion that allows us to
create realistic images on a concept
with only 5-10 photos so if you were to
for instance
fine tune on
um 100 images like back in the day it
was to come to
um
course full by means of computation and
also the data but Dreamboat allows us to
create a realistic generations with only
five or ten photos
and in this event we are going to train
our own Dreamboat models using Keras CV
and create applications on them using
radio and we will be hosting them on
hugging face spaces
um there is absolutely no uh limitation
on what you can find you know we have
four categories as of now and the first
one is natural animals in which you can
fine tune on your pet or
um some panoramas or there is there was
one foreign one instance where uh
someone fine-tuned on the Galaxy images
from James Webb Telescope anything that
you can think about nature and you can
fine tune on sci-fi or fantasy universes
which is one of the most most popular
categories that I have seen on hiking
face Hub and the third category is
consentful
you can partner up with an artist and
use their work to fine-tune on their own
style and train a Dreamboat with model
with it and we will be having a very
short briefing by Nema today at the end
of this event about it and the last one
is wild card which can be anything that
falls out of this these categories
and a couple of Inspirations for
instance the first one is someone
trained it on their cast and the second
one is the one I have just mentioned for
uh nature category is uh James Webb
Telescope diffusion which you can
generate new uh galaxies or
other space images
and the Sci-Fi Inspirations is it's
often that we see many
game or
um series sci-fi or fantasy series
Styles being fine-tuned on one of them
is this Urban Rink one and then you can
have this love polyisometric cyberpunk
creation and you can have
a fantasies word one which are super
cool but you can just use your
imagination and
create and Define tune on anything
and the Wild Card one is the one that
you can train on anything like first one
first example is balloon art style that
doesn't really fall into the previous
categories
uh you can fine tune on on a texture on
a style on even your own photos which I
did for myself in here you can see in
the last one we will accept it under
Wild Card category because it doesn't
fall into the previous ones
and for this Prince we have a
leaderboard in the organization page
which I will post later on in the chat
uh for each category we have three
prices uh and we will be ranking all of
the submissions by likes and the prices
include the natural language processing
with Transformers book hiding face Pro
subscription for a year or merch from
hugging face shop
again you can decide on them because we
didn't force it we didn't put a
limitation on what you can actually get
and you can make as much submissions as
you want for this sprints
foreign
actually starts tomorrow this is just
the kickoff event and this Sprint ends
in the 1st of April and in 7th of April
we will just look at the leaderboards
and decide who won it who won the prices
and then we will announce them
uh if you want to get started with the
Supremes you can simply join the hugging
face Discord let me just post the link
and take there is a role assignment
Channel I'm going to show this
there's a role assignment Channel over
there you can take the role Keras
working group member
and head to Keras working group Channel
and just join us there and there is
necessary information to join the
um join the Sprints we have a long
document and also we will be
Distributing free gpus thanks to Lambda
uh we will be giving 20 dollars worth
voucher which lets you train roughly
around the 60 60 models on a A10 GPU
and the documents that we have included
uh includes the details about the GPU
grounds and how you can get them and how
you can SSH into an instance and train
your own model and so on so all of the
details are included there but do not
hesitate to ask any questions and this
also applies to this talk as well if you
have any questions to any of our
speakers you can ask them
let me quickly see uh if there is any
questions for me here and then we can
move on with Nathaniel's talk
um
so there is one question do we need to
our category approved before fine-tuning
no you can just fine tune and just make
a submission even if your category like
what you have fine tuned on doesn't
really fall into one of the categories
you can still submit for a wild card
and it's the book of Lewis that we are
going to give away it's the hugging
Facebook where you have nature language
processing with transforms
and I will give my stage to Nathaniel
let me
think hello hi
Nathaniel is the first author of the
dreamboost paper and today he will talk
about
dreamboof would you like to share your
screen or slides sure give me a second
there we go can you see this
yep I'm going to remove myself and hope
you will have a great talk I will also
uh drop by at the end to see if there is
any questions or anything in the chats
that people would like to ask you
cool
yep
all right thank you so much and yeah
first of all I wanted to thank uh mervae
and the team at bolinario and and
everyone else thank you so much for
inviting me to this and it's really
exciting and super exciting initiative
so um I'm Nathaniel Ruiz I'm um I'm
working at Google and also a PhD student
at Boston University graduating soon so
uh I'm gonna give a quick talk on
dreambooth a lot of you already know
what it is so I'm gonna try to go
through the kind of pre-existing details
the stuff that's out out there pretty
quickly and then I'm gonna present some
new stuff that we have uh for an updated
version that's coming out very very soon
it just got accepted to cvpr and then
also kind of give maybe some inspiration
of um you show some stuff by some
friends show some inspiration for for
your personal projects probably
so um
um the inspiration for dreambooth is to
add controls to large diffusion models
so the fusion models had impressive very
impressive quality and diversity but
were very hard to control before dream
Booth so you have some amazing images
generated but you can't really
um specify you know you want this
specific subject in this image or this
very specific style in this image and
um so you can see it here for example
you know using image guided dally
Generations using the clip guided
conditioning you get similar images but
you don't get the exact same clock that
you want using text guided you know
prompt guided
um Imogen or Dali 2 you get you know
similar clocks but you can never get
exact the clock that you want in this
case and using dreambooth you are able
to get the specific clock that you want
um
so
you know this is kind of our our you
know main figure where you have this dog
and you can kind of generate the dog in
different contexts so that was one
surprising thing about dream booth that
you were able to do this
so well and also that it was able to
generalize the different poses and
articulations
so how does dreambooth work well
basically so this is explained using the
Imogen model but it works on the stable
diffusion model so in latent diffusion
models as well and basically you have
you know a data set of three to five
input images now people use more first
faces sometimes sometimes you can use
less and sometimes you can even get away
with using only one image
um
so the idea is that you have you're
going to fine-tune the diffusion model
so for Imogen it's the base model here
which is the 64.64 model
um and the core idea so of of dream
Booth is you have a data set and you're
going to fine tune a diffusion model
using a specific kind of prompt that you
give it and the prompt is a V and then
the class of the of the subject so in
this case a vdog where V is basically a
rare uh identifier that you can select
um so this works really well because it
tags the rare identifier and relates it
to the specific subject that you have
and also it's using this class label dog
to to facilitate this connection
um
and you do this you know you just train
this using the normal reconstruction
loss for diffusion models another thing
is so for Imogen you had these up
sampling models and you can also
fine-tune them for better uh you know
better accuracy for your subject but
latent diffusion models such as stable
diffusion don't have these and then you
also have this prior preservation
loss that we added where you want the
model not to not forget that the word
dog since you're using it already for
this prompt you don't want to forget the
association with like normal dogs so you
regularize it by generating images of of
different dogs or using images from the
internet of different dogs and then also
training it on the sentence a dog with
those dogs too so it doesn't forget the
concept and it just attaches the rare
identifier to your subject so this is
the basic idea of dream Booth
um you don't need this uh prior
preservation loss all the time only if
you require certain things such as
preserving the prior and sometimes it
gives more diversity but um the core
idea of dream Booth is here on top
basically fine tuning a diffusion model
using a rare identifier for a specific
subject
um so some new things that we have
that's the stuff that was on the archive
release version so now for a cvpr we
have some new stuff that is being
released very very soon so
um a data set right now this link
doesn't work but uh it will work later
uh today so I think I'm I'm uploading
the data set today and then we're
updating the archive version tomorrow I
believe so and on Wednesday it should be
there so this is this could be useful
for your project because uh we have a
data set of 30 subjects where we have
three to six images per subject
um 21 inanimate objects and nine pets
and then we also have a set of
associated prompts so this is a data set
that can help you evaluate your your
specific model so if you have models for
style then you can try to evaluate them
on these subjects and that's a good you
know there are no other data sets that
have kind of this variety of subjects
and also several images per subject in
different poses and and uh contexts
so that's the interesting thing about
this yeah we also have the prompts so we
have 25 prompts for each object for for
objects and 25 prompts for live subjects
such as pets
um so some quick things about so that
are in the paper that's going to be
released soon so the updated version
which are comparisons to
um textual inversion textual version is
another method that um back propagates
onto the embeddings of the text tokens
that are going to be the input of the
diffusion model and uh the idea is also
to get a consistent subject or concept
and sometimes it can fail without added
regularization uh and it's some it's
it's it's a little bit more finicky
sometimes than than dreambooth is it
does have some advantages so the the
embedding is really small compared to a
full dream Booth model right so but the
sometimes for rare subjects such as this
one this face dreambooth um performs
better
uh and then on the new version so I'm
going to go quickly through this but
basically you can check it on the
archive version
um in a couple of days we have some new
metrics so we um we come up with this
dynamometric which is basically cosine
similarity of Dino vectors for images
that are generated and real and this
helps for subject Fidelity so seeing if
the same subject is represented in
different scenes we also use the clip
image and clip text metrics and then we
see that basically a dream booth for
Imogen was the best one and then dream
of her stable diffusion came second
um
in the paper we also have this new user
study where we queried 72 users with a
bunch of questions so we have 1800
answers in total and we saw that uh
dream Booth um is better than textual
inversion for qualitatively for subject
and prompt fidelity
um okay so these are some also some of
the figures that you might be familiar
with that are in the original paper so
object Recon contextualization you can
grab a subject or object and then put it
in different scenes that's one very
interesting application of dreambooth
you can have artistic Renditions and
different styles that are already kind
of pre baked into the model
you can have you know text guided view
synthesis which is was a pretty
surprising uh thing about the the
project
um property modification such as you
know this different colors of cars or
hybrids of of dog breeds with other
animals
and then accessorization
so a lot of these you might have already
seen such as the comic for example this
is also coming out in the new version
um and then this you might not have seen
so you know we did also a study of like
how many samples do you need and
actually I I encourage all of you to
experiment how many samples you need
um because already with one sample
sometimes we're getting pretty good
results
um and two samples already for this dog
work really well uh for so for some
specific subject you don't need that
many samples which is very interesting
this means like the prior is really
really strong for some of these
diffusion models
okay so I'm coming to the kind of
interesting part of of the talk in which
kind of I give you some examples of that
some friends made uh on Twitter you know
that they've been sharing on Twitter
about you know their dream Booth models
and um first I'm going to do kind of
this application driven exploration uh
phase where I'm going to show you some
applications and those are things that
you might you know want to fine tune on
give you ideas to fine tune on to do
cool things
so one amazing thing was very early on
uh manual
um started doing this video game asset
generation so there's a startup
scenario.dg where they generate these
video game assets which are amazing so
isometric assets or like mobile game
assets and now they have their own app
where where they can you can kind of
generate a new new assets for video
games so I think I thought these were
really cool
um
also very early on there's uh dally two
pictures that was kind of like inserting
his own face into
um movies using impainting in an
incredibly realistic manner which you
know wasn't really doable before
especially with you know few images of a
face
um
then this whole like movement popular
movement of AI selfies came about so
those New York Times article about how
to do this I think there was an app that
um that was very popular for this
um so this is you know credit to John
Baron for giving me these images uh you
know this is what you can achieve with
it with a few images of of one person
you can kind of generate new images very
you know accurate images of someone's
face in different styles which is very
cool
um so called Yuga made these Custom
Custom enamel pins which I think are
really cool like I uh think the maybe
like the AI uh portrait thing uh sorry
the AI portrait thing uh is already you
know a lot of people have done it and
there's so much kind of potential for
other things such as these um these you
know object driven Explorations which
are really cool like artistic driven
Explorations that I think are really
really cool
I skipped this one so uh not on purpose
but yeah so a Roop it has some amazing
realistic artistic images that he
generates of people so these are all you
know this is a dream Booth model but
it's all um it's all kind of realistic
faces
um that are that look amazing
uh and then you know this I think this
is the last one so uh Ben Scott pie from
these thematic plushie creation so just
fine-tuning a bunch of weird plushies I
think he fine-tuned it on so this is
like a example of a feedback loop I
think he fine-tuned it on images that he
generated using dally too so he first
generated some cool images using dialing
two and then he
um made you generated a dream Booth
model a stable diffusion model
of these images and then he could
generate much more variety so there's
like a weird feedback loop here but you
can still get really amazing Creations
using that
uh and then finally to to finish my talk
I think I I went a little bit under the
time and so I'll have more time for
questions and also I can like revisit
some slides if if anyone wants to
um but there are some technical
Frontiers that I think are are
interesting so if you're not just
interested in
um in fine tuning on a specific topic
and then uploading your model there are
some things I think for specifically so
now so this is like a Kara's dream Booth
Sprint and I think Keras it has a lot of
unexploited potential especially when it
comes to the fusion models I think they
put out one of the fastest kind of like
training and testing and inference of
diffusion models of stable diffusion
very early on and I think there's a lot
of of unexplored potential here so I
encourage a lot of you to kind of like
maybe make up new tools for KRS related
to diffusion models and dream booth that
would be that would be really amazing so
here's some technical frontiers of dream
booth that that you can explore using
Keras
um for example
one thing about dreambooth is that if
you do the vanilla dream Booth so now
there's like you know later versions of
dream Booth use use uh less
um Less storage size you could basically
only fine-tune specific layers which is
another way of of generating a dream
Booth model you know you can just fine
tune for example cross attention layers
which is pretty obvious way of of doing
it
um and that would generate a smaller
size model that still pretty much Works
um so you know you can try to explore
the side of you know lowering the
storage size and the model size for
example using low dimensional update
approximations
um
and another Frontier is GPU memory
reduction so like reduce the memory
necessary to the GPU memory necessary to
train one of these models and there's a
a lot of different ways of doing this in
pie church and a lot of people have
already explored that but now with KRS
there might be like a lot of very
interesting different ways of doing this
and this really helps a lot of the
people that don't have huge gpus to to
do this right so I encourage a lot of
you to explore this as well
um so try to lower the time spent
training so make the training faster
um
and that can be you know there's a lot
of different kind of ways that you can
think about that you know you can think
about the scenario like the training
scenario change the prompts
Etc or you know there's a different
there's a lot of different ways to do
that which I encourage you to explore
another you know huge Frontier is like
can we get these models on device and I
think Keras
um has some packages that allow you to
deploy on device and that would be
really interesting to see some of these
models be able to be deployed on device
so a lot of things that you need to do
there is like a lot of these previous
things you need to to achieve in order
to get them on device like the model
size has to be smaller and also you you
have to have like faster inference for
example
uh and then the last one that I think no
one has kind of cracked yet is
generalization so right now
um a lot of people do early stopping for
dreambooth
um and they kind of like fine tune the
hyper parameters a lot so like they tune
their hyper parameters in order to get
really good results on a specific
subject and I think the next Frontier is
having one recipe or formulation that
fits kind of like a lot of different
subjects so you don't have to
um you know so this basically doesn't
stay as an art it becomes like a science
a little bit and that would be kind of
the next the next step there
um
all right thank you very much I want to
thank all of my collaborators fear Varun
yunjin Mickey and yell you know all of
this is thanks to them also a lot of the
people that we acknowledge in the paper
that helped uh proofread it and give
ideas and then
um just you know kind of facilitate the
process of getting all of this out there
uh and again finally I want to thank the
the hugging facing for inviting me I
think this is a great again I just want
to emphasize this is a great initiative
because a lot of the um the Keras
potential has been untapped in this in
this area and I think once it gets
tapped you know you might see another
kind of like small explosion in in the
creativity space for this
um so yeah
um and good luck to Francois later for
his presentation so yeah
um Merve if you have any questions for
me I'd be happy to take hello
um yeah sure we have a couple of
questions uh the first one that I picked
this to train a dream Booth model how
many images do you recommend to train
with is it necessary to have the images
and prompting for the data set okay I I
understand the first part of the
question and the second part I'm like
less sure that I understand but the
first part um so how many images do you
need I think I would usually start with
you know stable diffusion I would start
with five uh four or five and then see
if that works and then you can kind of
tune around that and it depends really
on the subject right um yeah it depends
on the subject or the concept so if
you're doing art styles I would say more
much more because you need um sometimes
the model doesn't have a strong prior
for that specific art style and it
really needs to learn it right so it
needs a lot of diverse examples for that
but for faces it has a really strong
prior it's just that faces we're very
good at recognizing whether a face is
the person that we that we think it is
or not you know like so we're very good
at discriminating faces so that maybe
that's why you need a little bit more
images like in the order of 10 images
for faces
um but for other objects
um you sometimes you only need you know
five or or less sometimes so I would I
would really explore that but I would
start with five in the usual subject
case
um so for is it necessary to have the
images and prompting for the data set
again so the prompt I mean for dream
Booth you have a specific subject and
then your the prompt would be a V and
then the class name and sometimes that
class name isn't even necessary if you
you know if you train it for long enough
you know you can try to tune the hyper
parameters for that so so um so you
don't need prompts for your specific
subject
um yeah and if this is talking about the
data set that is going to be released
then the prompts for generating those
images will be there
thank you
um
Christopher has asked how does it feel
to have your work have such a huge
impact outside of research Community I
think it's very that's a great question
yeah I mean I don't know I'm still like
just completely blown away it's uh it's
super surprising so
um from my perspective I just kind of I
was a little bit of State of shock for
like the first couple of weeks when it
kind of blew up but then
um yeah I just I really appreciate that
I made really great friends that are
making art and and really amazing
applications that's one thing that that
I that I love from my perspective and
um it feels good I just it never
intended it to to turn out this way and
now it just gives me more motivation I
guess like keep trying to to do that and
and seeing people just enjoying kind of
these things so yeah I think that's
that's the answer
um but it is a little I mean when you're
a researcher you're not usually kind of
like expecting this you're just you know
working on something like a paper uh and
when it has this like wide-ranging
impact uh it feels good but it's also
kind of like a little unsettling I guess
uh and it's hard to get used to
yeah
um last question is from apolinario and
it's do you have any high level tips for
hyper parameter tuning lover Higher
Learning rate how to find Optimal steps
yeah so
from my perspective like as a researcher
and this is not shared by almost anyone
obviously because it's like we we're
doing very different things I
um kind of I really dislike hyper
parameter tuning and I think a lot of
people are just way better than me and
at that you know so like I we release
dreambooth and then
um artists and everyone else kind of
became really really good at training
models before we did uh so because we
were thinking about more the technical
aspect so the way I think about this is
like I hopefully it doesn't exist soon
you know like hopefully hyper parameter
tuning doesn't even exist soon because
we have better techniques but um but
it's still like a necessary thing to do
so I do still have to do this but I
don't think I'm the best person to ask I
think there's like people that are I'm
probably actually probably you're way
better than me actually at this
um but yeah um so I guess how do I do it
um
I guess one thing that I would say is
just like law it's really hard to
evaluate these things so whenever you
have a dream Booth model it's really
hard to say whether it's a good one or a
bad one so try to find a way to like
distinguish a good from bad model by
having like a test suite and you
generate your test Suite of things like
a lot of diversity in the prompts and
and then you kind of have to like
eyeball it and say I like this bottle
like this model is good like maybe you
can rate the models and have and log all
of your experiments so uh just obviously
like the the typical thing just explore
one parameter one by one and log all of
your experiments like in a spreadsheet
and have like okay this experiment I
changed this thing and then this model
does as good or worse or better than the
previous one and that's kind of like how
you're going you're doing this like
weird uh gradient descent thing where
you know student gradient descent where
you're trying to like tune these
parameters
but I think a lot of that's the good
thing about dream with right now stable
diffusion is like a lot of these things
first for a lot of subjects just work
out of out of the box and you just need
to tune them a little bit to get them to
work really really well
thank you we can thank you so much for
uh joining us today I really like the
presentation and the the
further things that we can actually
explore with the dreambooth and thank
you so much
for your talk I really liked it
thank you merbe yeah no this has been
awesome and yeah good luck with
everything
thank you see ya
now we will have Francois chole
um that's me
do this
hello
hi hi everyone I'm Francois from the
costume at Google
um yeah and thanks a lot again for the
great talk I really enjoyed it and
congrats on the awesome contribution to
generative AI this is like really really
awesome stuff very impressive stuff
I'm gonna share my screen
yep
all right you should be able to see my
screen
yes thank you so much and
yeah I'm going to leave you for your
talk thanks a lot for uh joining us
today
yeah
all right so yeah
um just want to say uh to start with uh
thank you to to everyone being here
um contributing to agathan and also
thank you to the awesome Folks at taking
Fest for organizing the icon so my other
three uh quick uh just to give you some
quick context on uh Karas and the car
city package and the Civil diffusion
implementation to help in capacity
um so what's Keras TV first of all well
it's a first party extension of the cars
API that's focused on computer vision
components and we aim to cover three
types of workloads in particular uh so
the lower level workflow where you can
just compose your own pipelines and do
training and eval on your own data set
from scratch and also a slightly higher
level uh type of workload when you're
starting from peripheral and competence
uh like a pre-trained written a net for
instance that you can fine tune on your
own data and finally just a more like a
ready-made inference type workflow when
you can instantiate an existing model
let's say for instance an OCR model and
you can immediately start using it and
you can start serving it on different
surfaces so meaning like server side on
a mobile device in the browser and so on
and if you're into NLP as well uh then
you should know that there's also a
sister package of Castle which is Carson
LP casting is actually slightly more
mature at this time so if you're into
NLP uh check it out
um so Keras TV is very much a work in
progress at this time and right now our
current focus is mostly on
pre-processing layers we have a wide
range of about 40 different
pre-processing layers they don't just
process images they also process uh
bounding boxes and segmentation masks
which is usually you know pretty
difficult pretty annoying to do so in
this case the package has started for
you we also have about 15 different
backbones so backbone being a
pre-trained feature extraction model or
something like you know a resnet 50 V2
backbone
and something that we are starting to do
but that's not amateur yet is models so
right now we have the right internet
model we have the stable diffusion model
uh we're adding faster rcnn we're adding
segmentation models CR models and so on
we also have a couple metrics like
Google metrics and so on it's not it's
not really big focus at this time like
really starting with pre-processing
workflows and backbone models
and the goal is really that in the long
term we want to provide you with a
toolkit where you can quickly assemble
uh any computer efficient workflow in
just minutes so mostly detection
classification segmentation but not
limited to that you know we are going to
see more use cases that could see our
for instance in the future and we're
going to cover not just to the images
but also 3D Pawn clouds so 3D part
clouds is something that might seem a
bit Niche I suppose the reason we want
support for three point clouds is
because waymo is a big cars user so WeMo
is the autonomous vehicle arm of
alphabets
uh now the the company provides the
first fully driverless taxi service
that's currently operating in Phoenix
and in SF where I can basically just
book a ride in the waymo app and you get
a vehicle a car with like no driver in
it uh come to you you get in it it gets
you to a destination with no human
involved it's pretty unique it's pretty
yeah it's the future basically and it's
all built with gas models and so for
this reason we um we wanted to add
support for three point clouds so
obviously you know Lida data is also the
point Cloud
um so waymo is really just starting to
adapt class here at this time but
they're already a big cars through there
um and uh so besides just you know
components for uh creating like CV
workflows from scratch we're also going
to include pre-trained components and so
starting with backward models but also
moving towards higher level more
end-to-end models in the future and we
don't just want to provide a
models that you can use we want to
provide models that can retrain so for
any checkpoint that we provide we want
to make sure that the scripts are there
so that you can reproduce the same
training results
um that you can kind of check out how
the training was achieved I can look at
the tensorable logs you can look at the
hardware parameters that were used for
training and so on which is really
helpful if you want to train your own
model on your own data set you know you
need to know exactly how the the
original
checkpoint was achieved and lastly we
want to make sure that it's fast and
production right like we want it to be a
package for production and the focus is
really on apply the ml so that that
includes making sure that all models are
compatible with mixed precision and with
quantization which is uh really like a
must-have if you're going to deploy your
model
um really optimized on GPU and TPU as
well as all XLE compatible and inference
trading so compatible steel flight with
tfjs so that you can bring your model
into the browser uh transfer serving and
so on and so on
and so a quick reminder that it's very
much work in progress It's not mature
package yet it's moving fast and if you
want to contribute well we welcome new
contributors uh so right now we're
working on stuff like the Euro models
working cementation models and some
mobile Department demos as well
and one of the models that we have in
California right now is stable diffusion
and it also LED as a community effort so
Diva Gupta very quickly after the
original stable Division release uh
metaport uh absolutely efficient to
Keras and we kept working on it and it
got actually merged into Castle in
August and so today it supports stable
division U1 stable efficient V2 it does
text to imagine in painting out of the
box and we also have tutorials that show
how to do textual inversion uh dream
Booth of course and fine-tuning the
stable efficient model and
um if you're not familiar with chaos so
you see most of you are probably
familiar with scales but if you're not
definitely do check out the code it
gives you a pretty good idea of West
writing coding classes like so there's a
focus on conciseness readability
modifiability I think it's really
elegant code the entire project is only
about 600 lines of code and the
diffusion moderate safe slacks 320 lines
so it's it's really short really easy to
read uh it's a pleasure to work with so
do check out the code itself I think
that it's it's really good code
um and it's also very well optimized
code so it's about excellent compilation
under the box meaning you can write on
TPU this is really helpful if you're
doing dashed inference you can get your
seven casts quite a bit that way uh it
supports M1 M1 MacBooks and M2 MacBooks
out of the box as well uh there was like
no pascular special casing that we had
to do to get XLR compatibility or arm
compatibility and just worked it's also
ready to export to tljs and CF Lite so
we have it running in tfjs it actually
runs quite well it's decently fast it's
GP accelerated in Chrome it does require
a lot of ram so it's gonna it's a most
of your RAM you have to rent on big
laptop but it actually works works quite
well in Chrome uh and uh so it also you
can expose as well bars onto your flight
we have it training on a pixel 6. uh it
doesn't actually run very fast uh mostly
because it's uh it's largely not
Hardware accelerate it at this time it's
mostly on on the CPU uh so on the pixel
6 Pro I think it takes about 10 minutes
to generate one image uh so it's uh it's
it's basically too slow for your
production usage I think if you want to
use it on a mobile device uh you would
need to adapt the model so for instance
I know Apple made a full rewrite of
stable effusion uh to run on
on the iPhones and so on
um and the advantage of the cast if you
want is basically you don't have to do
fully right if you just want to
prototype your mobile app like you just
write the model with no special casing
of mobile or rtl.js or and so on
whatsoever and then you can actually
just move it to mobile it's not going to
be fast it's going to be optimized but
it's enough to prototype and if you like
what you see then you you can you can
actually do the rewrite
there was no special case in Hidden
uh so do check out the code it's Sangita
but cars team slash cars City and uh on
Casa tell you you will find a bunch of
tutorials we have just a basic text to
image uh intro uh we have tutorials
about how to do latent space walks which
is uh what you see on the image on the
right uh so you take two points and the
latent space and you uh kind of walk uh
along a path between these two points
and to generate like a nice animations
like this you can do textual inversion
uh dream booth and you can fine tune
your civilization models
and uh one thing I wanted to mention is
that really Keras is all about Community
it's all about people like you we are a
very small team at Google and none of
what we do will really be possible with
that Community contributions everything
we do is a community effort so in the
case I have stable diffusion and
solution tutorials I like to thank in
particular our cast community members
sayak chansen and divam so divamp
started the original cast policy Willy
Fusion second chance I contributed a
bunch of freeing right tutorials uh and
on the salary cast team Luke and Ian
made awesome contributions as well
so uh good luck and I hope you have fun
uh building stuff
thank you
thank you uh I see no one has any
question but I do have a few questions
so I wanted to ask firstly
um for instance when you're loading a
model from TF Hub with Keras they run
directly use it like how much
interoperability does it have with Keras
CV as of now because normally what I
used to do was I was normally loading
the models from kerastat models
and is there going to be because TF Hub
introduces more more and more models
compared to just implementing these
models as script inside Keras which
requires probably a lot of code reviews
and stuff so is there going to be any
flexibility and maybe even loading from
hugging face Hub directly how does it do
you have any yeah
I I don't think we need we need plans
for that I don't think we need special
casing of it
um krcv is not a new framework it's
really just a toolbox of Keras
components so everything in capacity is
just a car's components and
um when you when you instantiate like a
cast layer that you use to use it's used
to load a CF Hub model it's again it's
just a cast layer a SIM for invest
models so you can use them together like
there's no there's no restriction on
that if you want to take a backbone for
instance if you want to take a tfl
backbone put them in a crafting model
that is going to work so no no like a
special casing in the world map needed
um I wanted to give maybe a little bit
more context for those who don't have
contacts on the call on on TFM in
particular and what's different between
like a cast model like the the kind of
model we may have in class CV and the
tf3 model
um so a regular class model is defined
in Python code when you load the model
really challenges just instantiating
them alone by running the python code
and after that you're learning the
weights on tff it's slightly different
the model is stored as a static artifact
so it's basically a binary blob
including weights including a
computation graph that's baked into into
the artifact and when you load it you're
basically you're instantiating an
abstract tensorflow graph and with
weights loaded in it and uh your uh
basically putting in front of that a
Keras layer interface so that you can
manipulate the the the the the the
revived model the revived graph via the
grass API so it's two very different
ways of doing things so obviously it's
uh if you want to build a model platform
where anyone can upload their own models
it's much easier to do it the artifact
way because you just have to upload
files basically you're gonna have to
upload a code base meaning that there's
like code review step and so on but it
also means that you have less
flexibility because you cannot inspect
the code you cannot modify the code you
cannot do things like
um extracting videos from specific
layers and so on because it's really
just a black box I'll check
cool
um I have one more question that is sort
of answered the like half answered in
your talk I wanted to ask what is the
expected
time uh time interval to expect in a
complete interoperability of tensorflow
extended tensorflow serving or light
with Keras CV
right
um so if you have
um a Keras model in general it's not
necessarily classic Model uh it's always
going to be exposable to TF serving in
basically just like seconds or minutes
uh when it comes to tfjs and tier
flights it depends on the model so for
the classroom models we have this
commitment that they're all going to be
exploitable to the browser and to a
mobile device out of the box
but if you have just an arbitrary model
it can it kind of depends so the models
that you've tried so far in Canada CV
they could all run
out of the box but it's not always the
most performant right I think that's
especially true with tier flight the
thing we see a flight is that there's
only a subset of the GF light Ops that
are Hardware accelerated and your model
needs to be built in entirely uh with
these Ops basically
um when you when you export to tier
flights and tfjs as well one thing to
remember is that you probably don't want
to export your raw model you want to
export an optimized version of it not
manually optimized but automatically
optimized with things like quantization
in particular so we have a package
that's called the taskflow model
optimization toolkit which provides a
bunch of functionality uh you can just
you know bring your cast model or run it
through uh I know the the quantized
um wrapper for instance in the in the TF
model position toolkits it gives you a
new model which is more lightweight uses
fewer flops and so on and that's the
version that you should be exploring to
tflight on tfjs
it takes like the the end-to-end
deployment process take Slack typically
under under now
thank you and one last question is from
chat do you mind talking about roadmap
of Keras CV towards image segmentation
and maybe video segmentation later on
ahead sure so right now we have focused
more on object detection with image
segmentations the next thing we are
going to be doing uh video segmentation
is definitely on the roadmap uh not the
near-term roadmap uh we have very very
few people who are currently stuff and
by the way we are welcoming
contributions so if you want to work on
the video segmentation your
contributions are welcome we we can work
with you to to ship that
um if we are shipping it
um then it's probably going to take you
know at least at least six months like
we are focused on on other use cases
first
thanks a lot thanks a lot for joining us
today
thank you thanks for trying thank you so
much see ya
we will now have the talk of apolinario
from diffusers uh apolinario are you
there
um
yep hello
hello
I will now leave you with your talk if
it's okay can you share a screen
yes it is
foreign
[Music]
yeah
is it in full screen or
no it's on it's only uh
it's it's it's only the
interface with the slides inside and not
the it's like stem cells
I think this should work I'm going to
leave you to it
okay good luck
um hi everyone
so
um your your screen is gone now just a
second
you need to share again I'm sorry
all right
okay can you see it now maybe
yes I'm going to leave you to it okay
yeah sorry for that
um hi everyone I will be here talking a
bit about the diffusers Library as uh
yeah after these two amazing
presentations the first one on uh the
dream Booth uh technique and and the new
things coming to the paper I'm very
excited to see those uh that updated
paper and then the amazing talk on the
Kara's uh uh library and the the
philosophy behind it I decided to talk a
bit about the diffusers Library uh and
uh since this this actual Sprint will
not be used in the diffusers library
because it will be using Kara CD which
the filters does not support uh just yet
for tensorflow I will talk a bit about
the philosophy behind the diffusers
library because I think it can be pretty
expandable uh to any framework so it
just doesn't support it right now but uh
we hope to add support to more uh
libraries in the future and also you
we'll see how the philosophy of the
diffusers Library could be used even
in the current uh iteration of what
we're doing
um so first of all I'll start explaining
what diffusers uh is right diffuses the
modular toolbox for inference and
training of diffusion models right so
that's that means that the goal there is
to put different contexts of the
diffusion models in one easy to use
toolbox
um this is just a slide of a very quick
reminder of what the fusion models are
uh I'm sure this audience already knows
it but just in case I'll go very quickly
over it the two models essentially are
models that do a denoising diffusion
model process using uh yeah a denoising
process so you train the model to
essentially predict the noise from
and a random noise you input it a random
noise and then you try to predict uh
what noise will be removed until you do
it iteratively until you get an image
and uh why was diffuser is built well
the fusion model started getting
state-of-the-art results and generative
synthesis mostly for images but also in
other domains like uh sound and even
like human movement and other uh
strategies but they don't use
Transformers so diffusion models are a
new class of models and therefore we
couldn't simply include that in the
Transformers libraries too was too far
apart from the Transformers Library uh
context our concept or philosophy but we
had a similar set of challenges as with
Transformers so each model
implementation had its own research code
models were scattered with different
formats so like each person that would
release a model would have a different
format of different structure so
diffusers just made sense so the team
led by Patrick started this process
um so there are a few
philosophy fee for diffusers that I'll
go over it one is usability over
performance and while usability over
performance means is that
diffusers prefers to be
um easier to use and more compatible
over being Ultra performant out of the
box so what this means is that when you
use diffusers uh essentially the idea is
that it will always be loaded on the
maximum Precision of the model so the
model is for example trained on fp32 it
will be fp32 even if it's 16 for example
is faster
it would also be uh
usable in CPU out of the box so you
could basically the idea is that it's
the most usable out of the box but why
did I include the the meme on on why not
both there is because even though that's
the philosophy out of the box diffusers
includes a set of Suites to make the the
models Ultra performant on memory and
speed so actually the diffusers are a
fast way to to use diffusion models
um even though other philosophies was
ability over performance you have to
like go extra steps on the code we don't
ship like the ultra uh is the the ultra
optimized version out of the box but
with some optimizations that we include
on the examples you can get a super fast
performance
um there is also the philosophy of
simple over easy and this means that we
follow a bit the philosophy That
explicit is better than implicit code
and simple is better than complex
um so uh a lot of people think well it's
simple and easier of the double synonym
but actually what we mean by this is
just that
um if something looks simple to follow
to use to to look even if it's not uh
that easy uh that makes more sense for
for the libraries so the idea is that
even if it's a bit harder but it's
simpler
um that that's how the global philosophy
of the library uh goes but we will see
that that has a one exception down the
line
and the most uh controversial or
different way that the diffusers library
that borrows from the Transformers
Library uh approach is is that it's a
tweakable and contributor friendly uh
process over abstractions and what it
means is that
uh it adopts an important design
principle of the Transformers library
that we prefer copy pasted code over uh
has the abstractions and that's a bit of
uh contrast to a popular design
principle that such as don't repeat
yourself where it should be all
modularized the code shouldn't ever be
repeated but for for diffusers and
borrowing from the Transformers Library
we think that the self-contained unit uh
models or pipelines in the case of
diffusers make a lot of sense because
essentially it allows new people to
contribute really easy without having to
go through the learning curve of
learning the whole body of knowledge of
the uh of the dependencies that the
model has and all the the different
classes so basically every time you need
you want to contribute a new model you
can just study a previous pipeline that
was made copy paste it and modify it so
you have single contains and it's uh and
in a Community Driven Library this makes
a lot of sense as opposed to for example
uh libraries where uh are led by by an
organization or or a company or our big
teams so it's a it's a yeah we follow
that on on diffusers and more
specifically on each of the anatomy of
the diffuser models we have a few
different uh components so we have
models itself so those are the types of
architecture that diffuser support so
when we talk about models on the context
of the diffusers Library uh set those
are not necessarily for example stable
diffusion but actually the units to deep
condition model that the stable
diffusion uses for units that you expect
to the images
are considered models over diffusers
then there are pipelines and pipelines
are essentially uh what loads the the
different components for for specific uh
uh I like abstractions like the stable
diffusion for example the stable
diffusion text to image pipeline for
example is is a one of the most used
ones and the the pipelines they'll they
are made to be more like examples so
they are made to be uh essentially
self-contained uh examples on how to
combine uh models which are like the
United 2D of the stable diffusion plus
the vae plus the noise scheduler uh plus
uh yeah and then using that all together
so that those are the ideas that of the
pipelines we have uh more than 15
pipelines currently for stable diffusion
including techniques for example right
now we just included the control net
pipeline so every time there is a new
technique on the stable diffusion space
around the diffuser model space overall
for other models like there is a a very
good uh Dali 2 replication model called
Carlo if you don't know it I would
highly recommend you to try it out it's
a outside of stable diffusion just to
show that this ecosystem of the users is
not only for stable diffusion then we
have noise schedulers that are
essentially uh the
the schedulers for you to remove the
noise from the image that uh you have
for example the DPM
um pndm Euler and all this this
different uh schedulers to removing the
noise and on the fuse we also contain we
also include training examples so for
popular libraries and technique training
for example diffuser dream boot we have
training examples that follow this
principles and structures that I
mentioned before
um so yeah as I mentioned the filter is
currently pytorch only
um but for the relevance I think of
diffusers for this uh for this talk and
for overall this uh
Sprints that we're going through even
though it's not going to be using
diffusers as it is because we are going
to focus on on Keras I think it's cool
to see that for example sayak uh one of
the contributors for for Keras for
stable diffusion and also the person
that built the dreambooth Keras Library
our colleague and hugging face
he essentially yeah there is this quote
by him that he says that for him the
fuse restraining script gave him
confidence to re-implement in tensorflow
so you can see that all the philosophy
elements that I presented that led up to
to here uh lead up to what uh one way to
do the Dreamboat that we could years on
this event so yeah I think that's a bit
of the philosophy I hope that we can
expand the library towards more
supporting more
code soon or more more Library soon such
as not only using pytorch currently you
have pie charts and a little bit of
jacks but we definitely would look
forward to also potentially even
Community contributions and in the
future supporting more
libraries such as tensorflow and Keras
but I think the philosophy can already
be applied right now to whatever you're
using in the space So yeah thank you so
much I'm looking forward to see if there
are any questions or any further
comments from Margaret and anyone else
thank you
um for you I think there is no
no maybe we can wait for one minute we
are right on time as of now
let me see
there was one question about I don't
know if you checked the Keras
implementation but there was one
question about the comparison between
the that implementation and the
diffusers one
yeah
right I think that's my problems yes can
you answer this
yeah so I I actually don't I can't
compare the the implementation of
character deal with the with the
diffusers one
um because I haven't checked the the
Kara's one in depth but one thing that I
can say about this is that
um I think Karis has been doing an
amazing job on optimizing their
implementations on different Hardwares
which uh yeah have been proven very
successful to the community
um and I think that's overall the the
latest optimizations both for carers and
for for our diffusers are showing very
competitive uh results on on speed for
production I think as as mentioned on
the the library philosophy probably if
Harris is up as as Francois said in the
in his talk uh when if Keras is more
focused on
on on like having production ready ready
to use code
um that is a difference than where while
the diffusers Library uh doesn't have
that immediate uh Focus even though you
can't deploy your diffusers uh codes to
to production as well and that's also
encouraged and we have many ways to do
that very effectively
um as as mentioned in the in the let me
go back behind the like usability versus
uh performance uh slide it will not be
out of the box but it requires some some
user tweaking to deploying it to the
best of their outcomes so I think that's
one more let's say not implementation
like philosophical difference on on the
libraries
um and also I would say that uh at least
on diffusers we do make sure that the
the implementations of any models that
are on the users follow exactly the
original
paper slash code implementation so for
example on stable diffusion if you run
the code on diffusers you get exactly
the same image as you would get on the
original code base on the on the uh
companies or stability AI code base so
that's we guarantee like parity so you
can like you replace it I cannot speak
about how the Keras does it but just
that's another way to like
understand how diffusers Implement
stable diffusion on their environment
we have another question are we going to
support Keras with diffusers not sure if
it already exists
yeah currently the filters does not
support uh Keras uh our other Library
Transformer supports uh
um
but for the future right now we we are
focusing on building it it's it's uh
yeah I think we're not at the stage yet
to incorporate more uh libraries as of
now but that's total it's not out of the
question completely I think it really uh
depends on how the community interests
of artists would grow as well as with uh
yeah how many maintainers we could
potentially add to that so that's
definitely uh on our radar I don't think
it's on short term on our short term
implementation
plans to to include that support right
now but we are also happy to see the
ecosystem of the the kerosity growing
with stable diffusion and as and as
sayak did I think if we can borrow
philosophies from one to the other
um and and exchange knowledge even if
the library does not support it right
now I think that's still very powerful
but yeah I think that in the future it
could be that we support more libraries
including tensorflow and chemists
thank you I think we don't have any more
questions uh now I'm going to have Nima
thanks a lot for coming and this was a
very informative presentation
have a nice evening
bye bye
hi everyone hello uh I'm Nima I'm a
ethics engineer over here at hugging
face uh Marvin thank you for having me
uh I'm super stoked about the uh Karis
dream Booth Sprint I'm really really
excited to see what y'all put out there
and I'm here to give uh you know two
little slides about the uh consentful
prize category uh that we have for the
Sprint so just as a little bit of like
an overview uh hug and face cares a lot
about ethics uh case in point we
recently put out uh the ethical
guidelines for developing the diffusers
library and so I highly recommend you go
and check out the blog post
um but that post that guideline uh it
really documents like how the diffusers
library is being developed but I would
love for people to take those ideas and
carry them out into how they use uh
diffusion models more generally
um
so we have a set of uh sort of like high
level categories uh ethically that we've
been uh putting together to learn more
about these specifically you can go into
hf.co ethics or huggingface.com ethics
and you'll see a page that sort of lists
out uh our ethics like initiatives in
general
um and we've broken them down into like
rigorous consentful socially conscious
sustainable inclusive inquisitive uh
they're all quite different but in some
ways they overlap
um and today for the Kara's dream Booth
event we're specifically focusing on
consentful uh submissions so we really
want to encourage machine learning that
is done in partnership with people who
are affected by it uh in the context of
the fusion models that can mean artists
or it can mean uh people who are you
know put into models uh you know so
models that might be used as subjects so
when we're talking about consentful
machine learning in the context of the
Care stream Booth event
um I would love to put this out there
for you to uh you know integrate into
your uh submission process
if you have found some art that you
really really really like if there's an
artist that you're just a very very big
fan of and you are particularly
interested in reflecting their art
through a model
um my suggestion is and the prize
category recommends the you go talk to
the artist first uh so for this
particular category oops
I'm going to close that there you go for
this particular category
um all you have to do is reach out to an
artist uh get permission to use their
style and then if you go ahead and use
their style or their art for your
submission make sure that you include
proof in your spaces readme file
um that links to something that proves
that the artist gave you permission or
proves that the artist uh collaborated
with you on it so that could be a link
to a tweet it could be a link to maybe
the artist's website where they have an
official statement or something like
that so you know I I'm happy to answer
any questions around this or if you
write stuff in Discord uh we can help
you out with it
um but the basic idea is ask
and uh and you get uh you know another
prize category that you can submit for
it so that is uh about it for me I'm
gonna pass it back to Murray uh and
thank you again for having me
thank you so much uh I think there is no
questions for you but um if we receive
on Discord I will ask you or like they
can directly ask you
thanks a lot everyone for joining us
today uh this is the end of our stream
hope you liked it if you uh liked it and
if you would like to join us head to a
hugging face Discord and in the role
assignment you will see Keras working
group member take that and meet us in
Kara's working group channel so that you
can get started with the Sprint thanks a
lot
see you
yeah